mr speaker may i
begin by saying that i understand
and share the anger
up and down the country at seeing number
10 staff
seeming to make light of lockdown
measures
and i can understand how infuriating it
must be to think that the people who
have been setting the rules have not
been following the rules mr speaker
because i was also furious to see that
clip
and mr speaker
i apologize
i apologize unreservedly for the offence
that it has caused up and down the
country and i apologize for the
impression that it gives
but i repeat mr speaker that i have been
repeatedly assured
since these allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that
and that no
kovid rules were broken and that is what
i have been repeatedly assured
but i've asked
the cabinet secretary
to establish all the facts
and to report back as soon as possible
and mr speaker it goes without saying
that if those rules were broken then
there will be disciplinary action for
all those involved mr speaker